اهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا مراسلون ومصورون
وعاملون في مكتب العربيه في العراق فقدوا
ارواحهم او اصيبوا اصابات لا شفاء لها
طوال عقدين من الزمن في رحله البحث
المضنيه عن الخبر لكن العربيه لم تتوقف
يوما فالكلمه اشد وقعا من الرصاصه متابعه
[موسيقى]
قتل سبعه اشهر واصيب سته عشر اخرون بجروح
بينهم عدد من العاملين في قناه العربيه
مكاتب العربيه الواقعه في حي المنصور في
العاصمه العراقيه تتعرض لاول مره منذ
تاسيسها في بغداد لهجوم بسياره مفخخه
اننا فقدنا على الاقل ثلاثه من العاملين
في المحطه
ثلاثه او اربعه احد عشر شهيدا صحفيا خسرهم
مكتب قناه العربيه في العراق ففي الثامن
عشر من مارس عام 2004 خسر مكتب العربيه في
العراق اول شهيدين وهما المراسل علي
الخطيب والمصور الذي كان يرافقه علي عبد
العزيز بعد ان فتحت القوات الامريكيه
النار عليهما
تعددت اوصاف القوات الموجوده على ارض
العراق جواد كاظم العربيه بغداد
الصحفيون في العراق عرضه للاعتداء اليوم
كان موعد مراسل العربيه زميل جواد كاظم
ليواجهه الارهاب
كل انسان
عنده علاقه
بلحظه الموت قتل سبعه
اشهر اخرون بجروح بينهما عدد من العاملين
في قناه العربيه في انفجار سياره مفخخه
حيث تحولت المدن وشوارع العراقيه الى
اطول هل تسمعين
[موسيقى]
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام اينما كنتم والى
لقاء اخر وضعيف وحوار خسرت قناه العربيه
مرسلتها في العراق الزميل اطوار بهجت
اضافه الى زميلين اخرين هما المصور عدنان
خير الله ومهندس الصوت خالد محمود
[موسيقى]
نبارك
لاداره قناه العربيه ولجمهور العربيه على
انطلاقتها قبل عشرين سنه انا كنت من الناس
المتابعين لها منذ اليوم الاول لانطلاقتها
وكانت نقطه تحول في الاعلام
العربي المستقل
الاعلام الغير حكومي والغير بروتوكولي
والغير رسمي وكانت قيمه مضافه حقيقه
للاعلام العربي
طبعا
رحم الله كل زملائنا
ولكن دائما نقول الحياه هي اقوى من رصاص
الظلام اريد ان استوقف اخبرتني بالامس
يعني الصدف ايضا تلعب دور انت اصبت ب
18/6/2005
وكريم ابنك الله يحفظ لك اياه خلق ب 18
سته 2016 وبنفس الساعه وبنفس دقيقه تقريبا
اللي انا تعرضت بها
هل يمكن اعتبار انه انه دائما سنه الحياه
والفرح
يعني الولاده من جديد شو فيها دائما ستكون
بواجه الظلاميين وبواجه رصاص الاغتيال
والذي لا يريد ان يسمع كلمه الحق
انه كل احنا اللي عايشين على قيد الحياه
محكومين بالقدر يعني
ومرسومه اقدارنا ومقاديرنا مرسومه
الانسان
مهما واجه من صعوبات عليه ان يستمر ان
يقدم ان يعمل ان ينتج ان اعتقد يريدون
يجيبون كريم
راح نتعرف كمان
من المدرسه اجا مباشره
كريم كريم فخور كتير
عرف انه عندي نشره على الهواء وهذه قلت له
تعال حتى تصدق انه احنا خلف الكاميرا كان
موجود يعني ويراقب لا كريم بيك من اهم
الصحفيين وليس فقط يقرا على الورق انه من
يصنع الخبر على الارض كمان
عمليات الاغتيال نفس اليوم ونفس الساعه
وحتى نفس الدقيقه بالضبط
thank you كريم اهلا وسهلا فيك
يلا يلا
والان نريد جواد ان ننتقل لدينا ننتقل الى
بغداد ايضا مع عبد الكريم عطان القياده في
تحالف تقدم استاذ عبد الكريم اهلا بك معنا
يعني
تحالف تقدم الى اي مدى من المهم ان يتفهم
السياسيون
وكل من يتعاطف في السياسه انه الصحافه هي
تنقل الخبر ولا يجب ان تكون الخبر وان
تستهدف
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم شكرا لك اخت ميسون
وشكرا لك اخ جواد وتحيه لقناتكم الكريمه
واقدم لكم ماسكه التهاني والتبريكات
بمناسبه مرور 20 عام على هذا الشاشه
العملاقه اللي نقلت معاناتها وماساتهم
ووصلت صوتهم وايضا اترحم على شهدائكم وهم
شهداء العراق وشهداء الامه العربيه وعلى
الاخت نجوى وعلى كل العاملين لانطوا
حياتهم من اجل ايصال كلمه الحق من خلال
هذه الشاشه وحقيقه احنا همينا يعني تعرضنا
لامور كثيره يعني احنا قسم من السياسيين
تعرفين جنابك اني احترمها هذه الشاشه هي
والعربيه الحدث
ولانه الاعلام اعتقد اكثر من نوع يا اما
ممتاز او هادف او موجه
فاعلامكم اعلام هادف واعلام مهني وصل
الحقائق كما هي الى الناس نقل معاناه
الناس واتمنى ان يفهم الكل سواء كان
سياسيين او غير سياسيين انه انتم فقط
تنقلون الحقيقه والدافعون عن حقوق الناس
انتوا مالكم طرف لا بجانب سياسي ولا
بسياسه دوله ولا الى اخره ناس مهنيين
صحفيين طريقتكم انه تنقلون معاناه الناس
وصوت حر فاحييكم واحيي قناتكم شكرا
مالكين هذه القناه واتمنى لكم التوفيق
شكرا استاذ عبد الكريم اذا امكن توضح لنا
كم اسهم الاعلام بشكل عام
في بناء العمليه السياسيه في العراق خاصه
انه تعرف الانفتاح الاعلامي اللي اللي حدث
بالعراق بعد عام 2003 وتعدد وسائل القنوات
والصحوف والاذاعات
وانفتاحها بشكل كبير في العراق السؤال هو
كم اسهمت في تنظيج وبناء العمليه السياسيه
وانت سياسي
وقيادي في حركه تقدم
انت تعرف جنابك
انه
الاعلام
اصبح الان وهو يسمى كذلك السلطه الرابعه
وهذه السلطه ما بيها بدون رتوش تنقل
الحقائق كما هي يعني على سبيل المثال في
العربيه والعربيه الحدث نقلت ان معاناه
ناس قد يكون احنا ما نعرفهم حقيقه
نشكرك على المشاركه معنا اليوم
مشاهدينا منذ بدايات العربيه كان قدرها
تغطيه موسعه في مختلف بلدان العالم
لاحداث لم ولم تنسى جهود كبيره بزلها
مراسلوها العربيه ولا يزالون
دائما
لتعرفوا اكثر نستذكر معكم هنا مع التغطيه
العربيه قبل نحوي عشرين عاما
[موسيقى]
يشهد عدد من المدن والمناطق الافغانيه
موجه من العنف المتقطع عشيه الانتخابات
التاريخيه
اضاف الملا عبيد في تسجيل صوتي حصلت عليه
العربيه لذلك فاننا لن نقبل هذه
الانتخابات كما يتعلق بنوعيه الحبر الذي
يصبغ به ابهام الناخبين
حسن الرئيس الامريكي جورج بوش الامريكيين
على التفكير في مساله الامن
تتجه انظار العالم صوب الولايات المتحده
حيث يتوجهوا بعد ساعات اكثر من 100 مليون
ناخب امريكي الى صناديق الاقتراع
ولايه تكساس تعتبر معقلا ليس للجمهوريين
وحزب
[موسيقى]
دعا ابو مازن كافه الفصائل الفلسطينيه الى
التكاثف باستمرار عمل جميع الهيئات
القياديه في اطار السلطه الوطنيه الفحوص
التي اجريت حتى الان تستبعد وجود اي علامه
لسرطان على بعد امطار من هنا يرقدوا ابو
عمار مترنحا بين الحياه والموت
تحضيرا لدفن جثمان الرئيس الفلسطيني سر
عرفات مرحله تاريخيه جديده بدات برحيل
عرفات
[موسيقى]
ارتفعت حصيله الكارثه الطبيعيه التي ضربت
منطقه جنوب اسيا الى نحو عشره الاف قتيل
[موسيقى]
الزلزال الذي بلغت قوته 80 درجات فاصل
تسعه على مقياس
[موسيقى]
اقوى زلزال يضرب العالم
من الفوضى وتم سحب عدد كبير من هذه القرى
الذين حاولوا العوده الى مناطق المنكوبه
قرى كامله مدمره ومدن مشهوره تامه
الحصيله المرشحه لزياده كل ساعه تحدثت عن
مقتل ما لا يقل عن 30 الف شخص في سبع دول
[موسيقى]
جواد نحن سعدنا جدا بوجودك معنا تشرفنا
نتمنى لك العمر المزيد
والبطوله شكرا واحبك للحياه الذي جعلك
تبني عائله الذكرى العشرين هي المزيد من
العمل المزيد من الانتاج مزيد من الابداع
في العربيه والى الامام باذن الله